gut dass der sand ist immer so schön
ihres league vorbei hfc fanszene kro es
ist wie im erwachsenenleben nur etwas
bunter willkommen auf den mikrokosmos
spielplatz unterschiedliche
überzeugungen erziehungsstile und
temperamente treffen hier aufeinander
genau das interessiert in der kunsthalle
zürich wo sonst aktuelle gegenwartskunst
beheimatet ist entsteht gerade der
playground projekt der ausstellung zeigt
den spielplatz als ort zwischen ghetto
und paradies zum anfang vor der
spielplatz bewegung etwa dm sitzt heute
gar gesellschaft von kind schützen also
trend wo solche betriebe die gewachsene
belastet oder andere optik sind vor der
gesellschaft schützen vor der schlacht
am fluss foto gesellschaft auf 1000
quadratmeter wachsen skulpturen in die
höhe
ikonen der sandkasten architektur
erhalten den letzten schliff
die kuratoren gabriele burkhalter
erzählt mit ihrer ausstellung die
geschichte dieses besonderen ort
es geht wieder von neuem konzept worum's
testet werden wenn sich die abstrakten
skulptur wunderbar der angesichts der
bauspielplatz und des tritts konzept ist
echte landschaft spielplatzes nicht nur
auf musik und kunst die 68er bewegung
ein die menschen kreieren eigene
spielwelten lehnen sich gegen staat und
verwaltung auf in dänemark vergnügen
sich die kinder schon 1966 auf
selbstgebauten plätzen auch in der
schweiz zieht die bewegung ihre kreise
kampf der beton ist
archaische abenteuerland selbermachen do
it yourself ist trumpf
der sogenannte lotze wurm des schweizer
plastikers ivan pestalozzi markiert in
der ausstellung das ende der spielplatz
innovation denn in der 19 80er jahren
werden strenge sicherheitsnormen
eingeführt im wertvollen kinder darf ja
nichts passieren
schluss mit der wilden vielfalt der
vorjahre
die unbändige lust auf mutproben hatte
aber überlebt nur finden die heute gut
gesichert stadt und überwachen
je weniger das mit luca wenn man nicht
zu sehr fokussiert dann passiert
wahrscheinlich änderte sich genau dieses
grundrechts passiert
in der kunsthalle zürich ermöglicht
burkhalter eine internationale
perspektive auf den spielplatz
die aufbruchstimmung die bei uns vor 30
jahren stattgefunden hat spielt jetzt
auf der anderen seite der welt spielen
ohne angst
anders als bei uns das passiert ich so
groß dass obwohl das vielleicht
verhindern vielleicht stattliche risch
aus dass lee noma welt schaute auf dem
spielplatz geht es schließlich ums ganze
die kleinen lernen schon mal die auf und
ab des lebens kennen und die großen
können üben risiko auch mal zuzulassen
und die bedenken auch einfach
wegzuschauen